Donald Trump has done something very
very disturbing he signed a memo
reorganizing the National Security
Council and he has promoted former CEO
of Breitbart news Steve Bannon to being
a regular attendee at the principles
committee meeting of the National
Security Council to give you a sense of
what the National Security Council does
and what it is this is the primary venue
where the President of the United States
considers national security and foreign
policy issues with senior national
security advisers and cabinet officials
this is the council that helps the
president make decisions about national
security and former Breitbart CEO
Stephen Bannon is now going to be a top
adviser to the President on these
matters in contrast who is being
slightly pushed out to make room for
Steve Bannon the Director of National
Intelligence and the chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff are only going to
attend these meetings now Pat when
issues directly relevant to them are
going to be discussed for comparison
under Barack Obama do you miss him yet
the Director of National Intelligence
and the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
attended all meetings about Nationals of
the National Security Council which
makes sense and there's an article from
this morning from the Washington Post
called questions multiplied over
bannon's role in the Trump
administration this is the most
understated headline maybe of the
presidency questions like what the f is
going on here are the type of questions
that are that are surfacing could you
imagine that President Obama took off
the DNI or the director of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff from the National
Security Council I put someone on there
like David Axelrod there would be
outraged and rightfully so well David
Axelrod would sometimes show up right he
would sometimes show up at these
meetings to provide a little bit of a
layer of maybe the political
implications or something like that but
the idea of putting David Axelrod on
there is a permanent member and then
think DNI out chairman of the Joint
Chiefs out Steve benen is a professional
propagandist right he's the alt right
sweetheart with no experience whatsoever
in national security this is part of the
war on Intel Trump maintains the media
created the so-called conflict between
on the heads of the Intel community but
Trump loves the staff if you boot out
the people who are there to communicate
the Intel obtained by the staff you're
not really sending the message that you
love the work of the lower level Intel
staff and not surprisingly again
Republican Senator John McCain who is
the new voice of reason of the
Republican Party although he still says
crazy stuff on a weekly basis she said
that this makes no sense it doesn't take
a liberal to realize that this is a
train wreck and some Republicans get it
to John McCain of saying we have the
quote here on CBS Face the Nation
yesterday I'm worried about the National
Security Council who are the members of
it and who are the permanent members the
appointment of mr. Bannon is something
which is a radical departure from any
National Security Council in history the
role of the chairman of the joint chiefs
of staff has been diminished I
understand with this reorganization the
one person who is indispensable would be
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff in my view well yeah Bannon has no
job experience in foreign policy he was
in the Navy then he went to Goldman
Sachs then he did documentary filmmaking
and then he ran Breitbart news a
far-right website that pedals conspiracy
theories since when is running an
outright news website making more of an
asset to the president's national
security team then the Director of
National Intelligence you hear all the
time about how the left doesn't support
the military I'd much rather the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
the advising the President on national
security than Steve Bannon small
question I know stuff like the law
doesn't really matter anymore but how
can Steve ban and even beyond the NSC
without the consent of the Senate take a
look at this this is from the these are
rules from the 50 US Code section 30 21
on the national security council the
council should be composed of the
President the Vice President the
Secretary of State the Secretary of
Defense the Secretary of Energy and the
secretaries and under secretaries of
other executive departments and of the
military departments when appointed by
the President and with president by and
with the advice and consent of the
Senate to service at his pleasure
doesn't somebody
have some oversight over Steve Bannon
being on this thing according to the law
I mean you'd hope so ideally your
political strategists and the people in
charge of the National Security Council
would be kind of separated i can see
sometimes there's there could be an
overlap there but you have to wonder if
there's an ulterior motive here and
again this could all be part of this
idea of doing really extreme stuff so
that then when Trump negotiates back to
something slightly less crazy people
forget and look the other way gamefly is
sort of like Netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low use price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / tdps the games are shipped
directly to you would return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support our
show by going to gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s